foreign
of the Addie Hour podcast for those of
you who've been listening and watching
regularly you know it's been a while
since we released an episode so I'm
really excited to release this first
episode of 2023 and I'm also excited to
let you know that we'll be back to
regularly scheduled episodes where
you'll be seeing new idea episodes every
other week for the months coming up now
in this first episode I'm really excited
to introduce and talk about a topic of
burnout which might sound like a strange
place to start for the new year but I
think it's a topic that's really
relevant to many of us in so many
different spheres but before we get
there do you want to make a quick
announcement to all of you I actually
started a newsletter a couple weeks back
and wanted to make sure that you all
know about that if you want to check it
out you can find it on substack it's
called the Addie minute newsletter and
if you're looking for it just type into
your browser
n-i-i-a-d-d-y dot substack that's
s-u-b-s-t-a-c-k.com and you'll be able
to find that newsletter definitely
encourage you to check it out in
newsletter I'm going to be talking about
aspects of my journey also going to be
sharing mental Wellness tips with all of
you and also talking about some of the
upcoming podcast episodes and engaging
in further conversations around these
episodes it'll also be an opportunity
for you all to engage with me and to
also share ideas and comments and
questions that you'd like me to ask our
podcast guests so definitely encourage
you to check it out and with that just
want to go ahead and let you all know
about the two guests that are coming on
we're actually going to do something a
little bit different because we weren't
able to get both guests on the same
episode the same time so we're actually
going to release back-to-back episodes I
think you all are really going to enjoy
it we have guests from two different
spheres and two different walks of life
who are going to talk about this aspect
of burnout and really trying to help us
think about ways to thrive so with that
I did want to go ahead and give a quick
introduction to both guests the first
guest that will be joining for the
episode today is Dr Christine fund who
is a scientist with the Washington or
Wisconsin sorry with the Wisconsin
Center for Education research and the
Department of Medicine at the University
of Wisconsin-Madison Dr fund as I
mentioned is a scientist she earned her
PhD in cellular molecular biology she
followed that by postdoctoral research
as a plant in Plant Pathology but then
shifted for almost a decade was a
co-director of the or an associate
director of the Delta program and
research teaching and learning and also
co-director of the Wisconsin program for
scientific teaching and there she really
helped to train future faculty to become
better and more effective teachers Dr
findis also LED initiatives and directed
National programs around mentoring which
is where many of those of you in
academic spaces may have heard of her
she was one of the uh co-authors of the
original entering mentoring entering
mentoring curriculum and she's also
co-authored a lot of papers around
mentorship she directs the national
research mentoring Network and also the
newly established center for the
Improvement of mentored experience in
research so again someone who has been
deeply invested in mentoring over the
years and also co-authored an article
about burnout in mentorship so that's
the topic of our conversation and
something that I think will be very
enriching for all of us again we're
going to release episodes back to back
so next week we'll be bringing on a
second guest who is also going to talk
about this aspect of a burnout but
talking about this from the perspective
of a pastor so thinking about service
roles of pastors and those in different
Ministry opportunities and occupations
and different Faith Traditions but for
that episode we're going to have the
privilege of welcoming Dr David Ireland
Dr Ireland is the founder and Lead
pastor of Christ Church which is which
is a 10 000 member multi-site
congregation in north New Jersey that
represents over 70 nationalities so in
that conversation we obviously talk a
lot about leadership as well Dr island
is a former diversity consultant for the
MBA he's also LED Chapel Services for
the New York Giants the New York Jets
and at the U.S pentagon he's the author
of over 25 books including raising a
child who prays and he is someone who
speaks in a lot of different spheres and
and areas of impact has traveled and
spoken in over 75 Nations so someone who
has tremendous impact he holds graduate
degrees in engineering theology
organizational leadership and social
Innovation having also completed
post-doctoral work at the University of
Pennsylvania and at the University of
Cambridge in England so I know you all
are going to definitely enjoy that
conversation that's coming up one week
from today but with that we're going to
go ahead and jump into episode 35.
thanks again for being here I hope you
all enjoying this conversation
well it's my pleasure to be able to lead
off this conversation today as you heard
in the introduction we're doing
something a little bit different today
since both of our guests weren't able to
be at the recording at the same time but
we thought that just their both of their
perspectives would be really important
to share with you
um so this is going to be a little bit
of an experiment for us but I think
they'll still be able to riff off of one
another even though they're not actually
physically in the same Zoom room at the
same time but it's my absolute pleasure
to welcome Dr Christine fun to the
adjour podcast thank you so much for
being here
so glad to be here really appreciate the
invitation of course and I've heard your
name for years we finally got the chance
to interact a couple months ago in an
event and so in a lot of ways it's nice
to be able to engage in this work
together just with all that you've done
around mentorship and around this topic
of burnout as we'll talk about today so
definitely appreciate you being here and
even taking the time to be here with us
not to make a bad joke but I hope that
as you get these requests like I have
made today this does not add to the
likelihood susceptibility to burn out
but like I guess we can get into that as
well as we talk yeah we'll definitely
get into that
so before we go there my listeners know
and you know that I like to just check
in with people and see how they're doing
at this point in time so we're still in
the early phases of 2023 so just wanted
to ask how you're doing in the midst of
that um with everything that you juggle
and balance on a day-to-day basis and
just what your outlook is for the year
ahead
yeah thanks for asking yeah I'm doing
really well I'm still riding that high
of the holidays um you know which were
filled with lots of
family and friends and games and
laughter and food probably a little bit
too much food
um and uh yeah and feeling like getting
to ease into things and it's been busy
but coming from a place of uh having a
good rest a lot of good energizing
interactions and even coming in today
you know after Martin Luther King
holiday yesterday
which included you know a little bit uh
less stress schedule a little time to
sleep in a little time to reflect a
little time to listen to some speakers
and have some conversations with friends
so
um yeah I'm joining you in a really
grounded centered place today how about
you how are you doing today I'd say very
similar so I and I appreciate you asking
that question so um in the same way it's
been nice just to have some time to slow
down to pause especially with the Martin
Luther King Jr holiday as you mentioned
too which is always a mixture of the
pausing and the reflection and just
thinking about
things where we've improved things where
we still have work to do but again just
as I think very similar to you it's the
beginning of the year things haven't
really picked up at the pace that they
often do although I think that's
starting in the week ahead so for me I'm
actually just trying to savor that in
full disclosure also trying to have a
mindset where I can actually slow down
even with all the pressures and tasks
that have to be done but just to
actually slow down to make room to
actually be present in the moment with
all those and to actually be more
generative in the work that I do or in
interactions that I have whether that's
you know with colleagues or with
students or with family members so I'd
say for me I'm kind of you can probably
hear it Michaels I'm still in that
pseudo-reflective place and just
thinking about trying to put some good
practices into place in the year ahead
so that when things actually do pick up
that I can still kind of have this mode
of peace and reflection in the midst of
work as I'm going through it so that may
have been too much of an academic type
of answer but that's kind of where I'm
at at the moment so Yeah well yeah I
think I you know I hear us both kind of
just speaking into we're breathing you
know we uh I definitely I'm headed
actually
um made this trip yet uh last year at
the end of January I kind of flipped my
uh time off and actually on Friday
headed back to Mexico to do some scuba
diving and I only bring it up here
because last year when I went um if you
scuba dived you know that if you get to
a neutral buoyancy then you can control
actually how your body moves simply by
how deep you breathe in and how much you
let the air out you become buoyant so
just bringing that air into your lungs
will raise you up and blowing it out
will make you sink a little and
um and I just mentioned it because when
I came I went back I hadn't dove in a
couple years and I came out of the water
and I thought oh I had forgotten how to
breathe and I've been thinking about
that all year and when I get stressed I
just kind of imagine myself still scuba
diving and and having that ability to
breathe and control everything for your
breath which I know a lot of yogis also
experience and so I'm was just thinking
yesterday
um oh I'm gonna re-tap into my need to
uh think about breathing very concretely
uh when I'm under the water next week
that's great well I appreciate you
sharing that and I think and so I mean
with this things that we can apply from
that as well you know just going into
the air and again just being in this
place so that's a great yeah I don't
know if I'll be scuba diving anytime
soon I highly recommend it's uh it was
one of my uh my dreams uh I was
terrified to learn I was the worst
student ever everything that could go
wrong went wrong and yet it's become
something that I absolutely love to do
but it it took a lot of learning I was I
had a lot of fears to overcome
wow well that's great to hear I mean
there's I'm trying not to parallel this
to the podcast but there's so many
things in what you just said even about
resilience or about enduring something
that's painful and challenging and what
the reward is on the other side so okay
I won't go too far but just to throw
those out there uh go ahead peel the
onion layers if you want even though I
can go off on that for for quite a bit
in a good way but again I actually just
didn't appreciate you asking how I'm
doing at this point in time too so it's
it's uh it's refreshing to be able to
have that level of conversation I think
you know I think that Candor has become
more commonplace and I'm hoping that
that actually sticks um in some of the
circles that we move in so definitely
something that I appreciate
other thing that I was going to do just
to Pivot a little bit because one of the
things that you're known for obviously
for those who are familiar with you and
for those who aren't to introduce is
mentorship
um and something that you spent a lot of
time really investing in as a mentor and
as a trainer of mentors so to speak so I
was curious if you'd be able to share a
little bit about how you got into that
work and then eventually we'll tie in
how the mentorship and burnout piece
came about as well
sure yeah thanks for asking
um yeah so you know my college and post
college degrees are in biology
um so specifically I have a PhD actually
in cell molecular biology
um which means I had lots of
opportunities to be mentored in my quest
to be a scientist so I'll right out of
the gate say I have lots of amazing
mentors not everybody was perfect and
those ended up being incredible learning
experiences along the way I don't
actually think any Mentor can be perfect
but I think as a trainee sometimes we
expect that I'm not sure what Perfection
is in mentorship but um but that's
something we can unpack too but along
the way especially in graduate school
and and my postgraduate work
I just kept finding myself more and more
drawn to questions around how scientists
were trained to do things outside in my
case the research biology research
laboratory
um to do the other work they were called
to do if they were to go on as faculty
or in any kind of leadership and these
would include roles in teaching and in
mentoring other folks and the ability to
teach and Mentor has huge impacts on
those with whom they work but very few
scientists are formally trained how to
do either
um and so that became very much a point
of interest and Fascination for me and
so over the last 18 years I've had this
amazing opportunity to investigate in
particular mentorship I also did a lot
of work in teaching and learning but
we'll focus on mentorship for today and
that led to helping develop programs to
enhance mentorship and that led to
developing interventions or trainings to
help folks become better mentors and
better mentees and then that research
bug in my head really kept me talking to
evaluators and social scientists to
understand how those types of trainings
work and then finding out that there
were lots of research questions we could
ask about what does it mean to be in an
effective research mentoring
relationship what does it mean to have a
good working alliance with someone
what are the impacts of mentorship and
for who who and in what context and so
that's been really the emergent work
over almost two decades and I've had I'm
not trained to do any of those things
and have really learned on the job from
amazing mentors really
um kind of coming full circle so I
always like to say that I'm a scientist
who started um by studying
microorganisms and I ended up studying
people I think that's really well put I
appreciate the way you you've captured
all those pieces even the fact that you
mentioned that you weren't trained but
that you did learn from mentors but then
you've also now been invested in the
training itself and the science of
mentorship so to speak and being able to
bring those two together and I think
that's so important just to share you
know personal story I remember when I
first started my position again this is
within an academic setting but this
obviously applies in lots of other ways
but I do remember I was participating
like in a local conference and doing a
session on mentorship but some of the
other more seasoned faculty basically
were thinking well you're brand new what
can you have to share I'm interested as
if it was something that people just
learned by osmosis and just because
you're more senior that means you're a
good Mentor if you're junior then you
must not be a good Mentor so in some
ways real in many ways just appreciate
the emphasis that you've put on that and
I think similar to you even though I was
Junior at that point it had really
strong mentors and was able to learn
from them and apply those things so much
so that people can wait oh you actually
did have something to say and to share
with us as if that was somehow not how
surprising right
yeah I always love when people are
surprised
um yeah and I really you know think you
know early on in this work when we asked
mentors how they learned how to Mentor
we basically got two answers either I
learned from watching the mentors that I
thought were effective and I like to try
to do everything they modeled or the
opposite whereas I had horrible mentors
and I'm trying to do everything exactly
counter to what I experienced and then
it was basically trial and error and
even though every mentoring relationship
is idiosyncratic we have to understand
people are individuals and have
individual needs and come from different
contexts and backgrounds there are some
core principles like communication that
really folks can all including ourselves
always optimize and always be able to
enhance their toolbox yeah I highly
agree and even as you shared those two
stories I mean one theme that jumps out
to me from both of the doses both of
those were intentional people were
either intentionally trying to be like
someone or intentionally trying to not
be like someone else but had that
intentionality and how they moved
forward and again just in my experience
and I'm sure in the work that you've
done to the fact that you have to train
the intentionality is there seems to be
key because again that question that was
asked is almost as if
the person assumed that I hadn't thought
about mentorship because I was Junior
right we had it reflected on it exactly
yeah
one of um my dear friends and colleagues
and also a amazing scholar in this area
Dr Angelos Byers Winston
um who's also here at UW-Madison
um she always says and we also try to
Echo in all of our mentorship education
is that it's not enough to be well
intentioned you have to be intentional
and I think to add to that and
be intentional with tools and evidence
in your back pocket yeah you know you
don't come from a place of of not being
informed and that doesn't mean you have
to necessarily have read 50 books on
mentorship but take a moment to reflect
on why you're doing things yeah ask the
people you're working with if it's
working for them
those are parts of being intentional too
it's not just I decided I'm going to
lose weight this year and I'm going to
focus on it it's like well why hasn't
that worked before and who's going to
help me like there's a lot of components
to being intentional
I appreciate you sharing that such
wisdom and then that such wisdom that we
can definitely apply uh going forward so
and again I mean you're demonstrating
what you've already said at the
beginning of just how you've taken and
learned things from so many different
people from your colleagues and just
incorporate that and the work that
you're doing so I I appreciate that
you're you're practicing What You Preach
in a lot in a lot of ways so
um the other thing I know that people
are eager about this episode is this
topic of burnout as well I guess I'm
segueing by saying practicing What You
Preach because for our listeners we'll
also have another guest who will be
joining who is actually a pastor and a
leader who also has talked about these
aspects of burnout but then also
mentorship and coaching
um in different roles and those who are
in pastorals in the ministry so again
you know we've talked about this
intentionality
um and moving things for it but there
can also be extremes of that and not
even extremes especially in service
roles when you're so invested in other
people they can easily lead to a place
of burnout
um so Chris I was wondering if you could
just share how the burnout topic even
came up within this realm of mentorship
and what what brought that about because
I imagine it's something that's not just
imagine I know it's always been there
but not always talked about
yeah uh it's actually uh how how the so
we wrote a piece uh my colleagues and I
and I'll I'll mention who I'm talking
about in a minute for the Harvard
Business Review in last year and it's a
a funny story actually how it came to be
so
um maybe I'll share a little bit uh with
listeners because I also think it's
about how things just happen
um but you have to be looking for them
so
um I there are four of us worked on on
this piece for Harvard Business Review
um so Ruth um gotian and chaveso cook
and Brad Johnson
um and so Ruth uh is a chief learning
officer and assistant professor at uh
Wiley Cornell
um medicine in New York and then um
traviso uh is goes by Chevy cook he's
actually a US Army Lieutenant Colonel um
and he's at Fort Meade but he also runs
this non-profit called military mentors
and then brand Ed Johnson he's actually
a professor of psychology in the
department of leadership ethics and law
at the U.S Naval Academy and he also has
a position at John Hopkins these three
folks have been kind of what I'll call
in the the science and practice of
mentorship world for quite a while and
they've written different types of
things and they study different types of
things and as you can imagine just from
hearing where they work and we've all
known about each other's work and we've
all been fans of each other's work but
we haven't been in the same space as
necessarily and over the last about four
or five years
we'd end up finding ourselves in the
same room but not all together so two of
us would be at one thing and then two of
us would be at something else and every
time that would happen the group that
was physically together on Zoom or or
physically together in person or on Zoom
would say oh we have to write something
together
and each of the different folks had
written with each other so this happened
again
um in early spring uh 2022 is
um Chevy and I were at a meeting we so
we have to write something together and
I said oh well Ruth has been saying we
have to write something else together
and
um and then Brad was at this meeting too
and he's like well I don't have a lot of
time but we should write something
together so we finally all got on a zoom
call
no idea what we were going to write
about literally just said we all admire
each other we're all thinking in the
space we should surely if we got on a
call together we could come up with
something we should write together
um and so I like to share that part
because I think that from the outside it
sometimes looks like everything is
structured and it came to a conversation
and you better show up with a brilliant
idea otherwise why would you show up no
we literally got on a call and said all
we want to do is do something together
we don't know what we should do and so
we started talking and and everybody
said oh yeah it would be great to write
something together but I'm too busy I'm
kind of burnt out I'm kind of tired you
can see where this is going oh wait a
minute maybe I've been talking to
mentors and they've been talking about
being burnt out and I'm kind of feeling
burnt out and and then Brad Johnson said
I've actually written a topic about
Mentor self-care in 2018 and about how
to avoid burnout and so really like
within an hour we had said that's it
we've got to write something about
Mentor avoiding Mentor burnout and we
literally just set up a Google doc and
we started throwing things in it and
then we met like two more times and we
did the whole thing in a couple of like
several weeks and then
um and then fortuitously it turned out
that Brad had a connection at Harvard
Business Review they were looking for an
article so you know it just kind of
happens that way
um in the networking but it really was
interesting because when we finished and
we wrote it and we can talk more about
what's in the article if you want
we all said
that we felt really re-energized after
writing it even though we had put
something new on our plate and you and I
were joking before we kind of started
the podcast is like oh I hope I didn't
like make you feel burnt out because I
asked you to do the podcast or for you
thinking you're doing one more podcast
but we realized that you know there is
something
in just thinking about burnout
in thinking for why am I feeling that
way what things energize me what's
drawing my energy away
and this article energized us that
actually helped us feel less burnt out
than when we decided to do it so that's
just a little bit of kind of how it
actually all played out um and it was a
wonderful thing to do with three amazing
colleagues that we had all wanted to do
something together and then we all felt
better wow
that's amazing I mean I appreciate
hearing how you all were attentive to
what you were experiencing in that
moment too I mean just the fact of
naming it seems like it was so cathartic
isn't the right word but just just yeah
well and then someone would say this
week I I don't have any time and someone
else would say well I'll work I'll spend
30 minutes on it this week and then I'll
hand it off and
so it became kind of the process of like
all the things we were saying in the
article of them saying wait am I doing
that yeah yeah
um which is always you know a little bit
scary uh I thought about you know when
you asked me to be a guest is
that the thing I was most nervous about
was not how many
ums and not would I say something that
didn't sound smart or it was mostly if
my friends or colleagues or family
listened to it would they tell me that I
had been authentic to how they were
experiencing me dealing burnout wow
yeah that makes a lot of sense I guess
that level in a sense of uh
accountability
yeah right was I going to get on and be
like well here's how you avoid it
you were so burnt out
um just to be honest and I think that
taking time to just be honest about what
it means uh when we feel burnt out has
been really important I I was thinking a
lot about since writing the article and
thinking about it I've done a lot better
job of querying
burnout what does that mean when I say
I'm burnt out or I hear someone say
they're burnt out
first I want to validate that in myself
and others but also to say what is
what does that actually mean does it
mean I'm exhausted to the point that I
need to go sleep for three days does it
mean I'm actually just irritated by
everybody asking me for something and
actually if I take a walk I'm gonna be
okay
or am I really at a place of such
burnout that I'm being cynical I'm being
inefficient in everything I do because
my mind's wandering because I can't
focus
um but that's been really helpful in
listening for in myself and others is
when we say that just investigating it a
little bit
that's really good how have you helped
people to do that I'm curious and even
in the weeks I know you centered the
article kind of in the history of the
term so I'm curious how you have uh
suggested people apply that you know to
their own situations and then also based
on how they apply that how do they
actually move forward to kind of move
out of that place of those not tiers but
different modes of burnout yeah and I'm
certainly you know not an expert in
helping people you know definitely not a
therapist although my mother is one
um is uh so but I do think that you know
well I could even say to you so you know
the last time you felt really burnt out
is think you know think about what you
were feeling think about the weight of
it
um how big did it feel did it feel
all-consuming was it only in certain
contexts was it every day was it only
when you were dealing with certain
issues
um to try like to just examine it a
little bit so I think that it's not one
specific way but to allow someone to
explore tell me what that feels like
tell me when that happens
tell me about what you do when you feel
like that so that then we can kind of
say oh
wow so it's sounding like whenever you
think about
let's just use for example the enormous
weight of Parental care that you're
engaged in that's where it's really
feeling enormous
and that it's trickling into all of your
work but that is at its core is where
your burnout's coming from and so you
know what could you do around that
no I think that's really helpful and I
mean even just doing a mental exercise
as you were asking that and thinking
about getting back to even mentoring all
the different types of mentoring roles
that I have and if I had to say oh well
I couldn't notice some specific patterns
of certain types of roles where there's
more of a burnout feel or feeling too
spread thin and thinking about you know
well then I might not feel like I have
as much time to respond to those things
or feel irritable about those things or
even in that exercise I think that's
really helpful to kind of piece through
it and think about in that very
pragmatic way
I'm also curious you know as you wrote
how did people respond to the article
because I could see it going in
different ways I could see it being
refreshing for people I could see
sometimes people being reactive to it
um Maybe not maybe needing to hear it
but not wanting to um and that's put
words in about but those are just things
that kind of come to mind as I think
about people how people might have
reacted but I'm curious what your
experience was and how people responded
yeah I think you hit the nail on the
head is it was a little it's a little
bit of everything so
I think for some it it provided
validation for how they were feeling
that they could say yeah I know this
mentoring work is important but it's
exhausting sometimes
and just to be able to say it
it doesn't mean you're not committed to
mentoring it doesn't mean you don't want
a good job but just it's okay to say
that it takes energy and it's and you're
tired
I think it encouraged some mentors to
take a minute to look for signs of
burnout in themselves and others and be
honest about where they are but then the
answer could be difficult
and I think when the answer is I am
burnt out
and I need feel like I need to take a
break from mentoring and I feel like I'm
in a position that I can't because of
who the consequences whether that be
political whether that be for promotion
and tenure in the academic setting
whether that be consequential to the
people you're mentoring
but one of the things we tried to raise
in the article is
it was kind of we didn't call it this
but it was kind of like if you're Faking
It so if you're trying to Mentor from a
place of exhaustion and burnout you're
probably not doing a good job and this
was actually couched in a term
um by one of the wonderful mentorship
Scholars
um uh Bell Rose raggins who actually
called it marginal mentoring where
you're basically engaged in
dysfunctional or disengaged mentoring
because you're so depleted so you might
think fine I'll meet with all seven of
my mentees but if you're really doing
that from a place of exhaustion there's
consequences to that in terms of the
kind of mentorship You Are
and I think that was the other thing
that um that we really got some
interesting feedback on was the
permission and suggestion to talk about
burnout with your mentees
to normalize that conversation that that
there are imperfections if you even want
to call it there's normalcy there's
coping there's avoiding and that when
mentors could tend to continue to try to
model that they never get burnt out and
they're never tired
um
the mentees begin to believe they cannot
do that job
because they'll say I'll never be able
to do that without saying I'm tired
sometimes
so I think that was one piece we wanted
to give people and the encouragement to
be realistic and honest about
there's ups and downs there's burnout
there's exhaustion and model how to do
it model is a mentor of saying I can't
meet with you this week it's not because
I don't care it's because I actually
probably won't be helpful because I'm
just burnt out
yeah
and that being okay yeah I mean
obviously there's content people can be
in crisis we're not saying like
someone's in crisis and saying I can't
help you at least to refer them to
someone else but in the day-to-day yeah
um yeah and I think back to that there's
risk of just pushing through as a mentor
um so I think you know those were some
of the things in terms of feedback and I
think you're right I mean for for some
folks we don't want to think about it or
we or mentors say well yeah that's nice
but I'm trapped yeah I'm not a big
per
I I will remember all the way back to
high school
um is one of my most influential
teachers one of the exercises they would
do is that whenever you were feeling
trapped they said you had to come up
with at least three approaches to the
situation you were in you could not only
come up with two
and I always think back to that because
I think when we feel trapped the
exercise of saying how could I get out
or how could I change it is to try to
think Beyond one or two options
now that's also contextual yeah so you
know I know one of the things that we
can talk about in a little bit is not
everybody gets asked the same amount of
service work or mentorship not everybody
has the ability to have folks um help
you know some of some folks have a lot
of additional family help they have
access to money that they can throw out
the problem you know you know folks
they'll be like oh you're burnt out just
go just go on a spa vacation well that's
not accessible to a lot of people for a
lot of reasons and and that's lovely if
you can do that but that's probably not
an answer that's going to really
resonate with a lot of people who feel
like that's completely inconsiderate of
our inequity and access to those kind of
things
taking a walk it's a little bit
different believing you don't have five
minutes to walk because you feel so
crunched and saying to somebody I really
want to encourage you to just take a
moment and and hear what you're saying
that you don't have five minutes like
that makes me sad that you feel that way
so let's talk about why you feel that
way
um but yeah so I think the an article
like this triggers all of those things
yeah yeah I mean there's so many layers
there and just the way that you've
brought all those to light even as you
were talking about the modeling as we
talked about from the beginning
mentoring
well from learning from either good
models or poor models and just the way
that acknowledging that burnout can be
such an example I think is huge then
even all the other pieces that you
mentioned as well and you know a lot to
unpack there but just the guilt that
comes with that sometimes the Perfection
doesn't come come with that sometimes
but then even the inequities as you
mentioned and all the complexity that
comes with that a topic that I'm sure
that I know you all touched on as well
is the the mentor as well and whether
that whether it's a female Mentor
whether it's someone from an
underrepresented group and the
additional burden that comes just in
conversations that I've had with so many
people in personal experience of knowing
that some of our mentees feel like they
can't go to anybody else which then adds
another layer of guilt
in the sense that we can think if we
don't mention this person who will and
there there is true to that to some
extent too but then how much that can
also lead towards that burnout
um so I appreciate the way that you
brought that up in the article I'm just
curious you know if there's anything
you'd want to expand on that on that
tench that real tension that's there as
well because obviously you can also get
to a point after you mentioned of
mentoring so many that you become
ineffective so where I know there's no
perfect there is no perfect answer but
how have you yeah the police described
that and how have you been thinking
about some of those uh yeah and I don't
know that you know when you're writing a
short article for
um
you know for a publication like a hard
Business Review you know you're going to
get crunched and so you can't really
unpack all of that you know you can
leave little breadcrumb Trails for that
but
um but I think that's one of the great
things is you get a lot of people kind
of thinking about it a lot of
um
um publicity around it but you don't get
to really dig into nuance and and that
can that can rub people the wrong way
absolutely it's like because you get
this sense like it's not that simple and
then you know part of it is you know
hoping that the author is no it's not
that simple and we're limited by space
um but also there's sometimes when you
know authors miss things I'm sure we
miss things too or folks thought did you
not consider
um and there are probably many thoughts
people had about things that we didn't
consider and is Room to Grow I do think
you raise
um especially around I mean we know you
know
and I'm sure many of you know the guests
you've had before no that individuals
from underrepresented groups they get
asked to do more of this work I mean
let's just more of the mentorship work
you know when we're talking about
academic settings you know we know
they're asked to do more mentorship work
more Equity inclusion
um diversity Justice work more
psychosocial work
so there's a huge inequity about what
they're asked to do and it's not just
what they're asked to do by leadership
it's what they're sometimes
um articulated and not articulated
expected to do by their peers
and then what they are asked to do by
folks who feel like they share certain
identities with them and even though I
think there is a real call to White
identified folks like myself to take
some of that burden on and to do the
work that's needed to be more culturally
responsive and to be a more culturally
responsive mentor and we do a lot of
that type of training is at the end of
the day is there's a lot of mentees that
are wary
that don't trust have every right not to
trust that someone like me could hear
them and support them
um no matter how much I've prepped
um and at a minimum even if they believe
it don't want to start there
and so that puts additional burden on
folks like yourself and so and you know
I know there's a lot of talk and effort
to make that work valued and to
compensate it but again
no amount of compensation buys you time
it doesn't buy you
um a refill on the emotional drain
um and so I think it should still be
done I I'm a big fan of being
compensated for that work
and it can't be the only answer because
it can't solve all of the burnout that
is unequal unequally divided amongst
people
you know it's really well said and even
even as you're talking about it really
resonate with the not being able to buy
time but in a way it also made me think
about the experience that you all had as
authors as well even just naming that
burnout and just the power that can also
come from having conversations like this
or for those of us who are from you know
overlapping backgrounds having the space
to talk about that together and this is
just anecdotal this is not evident space
but just as I've been reflecting on some
of the things that you said and so many
other guests have shared about the work
that they do just being in the room I
mean so many people have come on this
podcast and even made that type of
comment about the conversations they've
had here now that it removes the
challenges or the burnout that may come
but just to be able to kind of walk
through that and think collectively
about ways to navigate that I think can
be really powerful as well well and it
could be compounded you know we know
that um one of the things I don't
um
um that I think one we talked about when
we were working on the article was you
know data like Women's Physicians spend
on average two minutes more on each
patient patient than men and are more
likely to explore the socio-emotional
and psychosocial issues during the visit
and you know I know Brad Johnson had
um referred to that in some of his
earlier work so it feels like just two
minutes but two minutes and the type of
emotional work over time yeah
across a day across a week across a year
it takes a toll and it's not equal
um I think the other thing about burnout
too is
um you know I I have a lot of um
uh feel very honored that I have a lot
of friends and colleagues who you know
will challenge me call me out and I
remember one colleague uh saying I
remember this was way before we worked
on the article but I remember saying
something like oh I'm just feeling so
burnt out on all this work and and she
knew I acknowledged there was uh
inequity and who held work and all of
that
but it was this kind of off the comment
but it has sat with me and I think
there's so much power in it
um and and she's a black identified
individual and she said I felt burnt out
you feel burned out right now I feel
burnout every week of every day for my
entire career and
I just had to stop
and even think about
folks talking about burnout wanting to
honor their burnout
but also calling people to contextualize
their burnout
even burnout has privilege in that we've
had episodic burnout as to post a
consistent burnout and I think those are
just things again I want to honor the
individual experience and not
um devalue anyone saying they feel burnt
out that's not my intent but I think
it's important for us to realize that
even in our speaking into the space we
are not all talking about the same level
of burnout the same causes of burnout or
the frequency at which we're feeling it
yeah yeah I think that's really well
said as well and just again I have no
idea what it would feel like to feel
burnt out my entire career every single
month of my career that is an absolute
foreign concept to me because I've had
the privilege not to feel it yeah
but even even in hearing that
challenging Story part of me feels
encouraged that you all had the space to
have that
conversation and then as you've
mentioned even with the article itself
too like there's just such a need to be
able to unpack that I think like in that
context if even if it's let's say there
were two other individuals who are
having that same conversation to be able
to then delve in and really understand
what that means
so much learning that can happen from
that and the learning obviously isn't
enough in and of itself but again it
just seems like it creates this
opportunity in a sense and maybe not
being too optimistic but just to have
community in that sense to be able to
share those two different experiences
even you say I can't imagine what that
would feel like to have someone voice
that to you and then to have a dialogue
yeah there's a lot of power that comes
from that as well
yeah I um
I it's it's such a
it can be such a scary space and it's
where the most amazing learning is
happening yeah which is you know why I'm
so appreciative you're doing the podcast
series because it creates space for that
um I was saying you know before we
started you know I was really so loving
the experiment in you being
accommodating of the schedules of myself
and Dr Ireland and I would have loved to
have been on the same space but
um but the fact you had put us together
got me really thinking
about my faith
my Christian upbringing what's the
narrative in my head and heart about
service
and being a servant and being selfless
and burnt out
um and so I'm really excited to hear the
whole podcast world together
um to hear thoughts on that
um but I really I've really spent
um
a couple weeks not consistently um but
since your invitation wrestling
around you know the
messaging and and my belief that we are
called you know in my Christian faith in
other faiths but I can only speak from
my you know my lived faith
to
to embrace service to the point of
selflessness
and that and that were the narrative
that's written is that that will fulfill
you that you will be gain energy from
that
um but then I know that if you give to
the point of collapse it serves no one
and
um and so just sitting in that Paradox
for lack of a better word
I don't have an answer but I've realized
I've had I don't I haven't reconciled
those
and this you brought the word guilt you
know and you know I've been up late I've
been working with a really wonderful
leadership coach in the last year and I
am you're probably not surprised I
totally subscribed to Servant leadership
but as our work has grown I have
realized that that can't be my only
approach because it's actually
impossible
because I can't be in service to
everyone and just keep it growing it
there becomes a limit yeah so I have I'm
having to change my leadership style and
I feel a little guilty about it
so yeah you're saying yes like you've
been so I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this too and and but I hadn't
considered how wrapped up that struggle
was in my faith and this has really
afforded me the opportunity and to
really think about that because of the
pairing you put together for the podcast
I don't think I would have gone there in
my thinking yeah
so I'm curious like yeah you had a very
interesting look on your face so I'm
really curious what you're thinking
right now yeah you definitely you
definitely picked up on it and
partially I mean before we wrap up I'm
gonna also ask you if you have any
particular question you'd like me to
post to Dr Ireland as you've been
thinking through this as well but I can
definitely relate in a lot of ways
um even going back to when you were
asking early on for me to think about
times when I felt burnt out or even when
you were doing the check-in early on so
that's part of the conversations that's
that's come up in my leadership coaching
as well specifically around mentorship
um so
thinking about how that has shifted over
the years as I've gotten more and more
involved in different groups and
different initiatives I mean full
disclosure whenever I tell people what I
do
not even on a daily basis but just in
general people always ask me if I sleep
that's always the next question that
comes up which is an important question
but it also means that I can't be
involved in mentoring the same way I was
13 years ago when I started the lab or
you know scale to do things that I've
done now and even I even share this as
I'm mentoring others in leadership
positions too sometimes I have to make
difficult decisions about do I take this
one-on-one mentoring opportunity here or
do I take an opportunity to go speak to
a group of 50 people at once and share
it and that is not a numbers thing per
se but there's also an effectiveness
and I don't want to call it efficiency
but it doesn't feel like the right tone
for mentorship but also like how how
much can I get this information out to
people who need it so even in the
leadership coaching that I've been
having having those feelings of guilt
and being coached and told that those
are going to come and I basically just
have to ride them out because I can
either try to address the guilts and
continue doing things the way I was
before and
move towards a deeper phase of being
burnt out or I can be wise about it try
to spread things out try to to nominate
and have others step into those roles to
limit some of my mentorship which feels
bad and there's guilt that comes with
that because sometimes there are really
important needs so I think I'm right
there and you probably you could sense
that as you were sharing that right
there in the middle of that and trying
to think about that even going all the
way back to the first question you asked
about the check-in because even right
now I'm starting to write a book
proposal and doing those types of things
I have to be very disciplined in setting
aside time to do that or it's never
going to happen which means I have to
say no to some mentorship opportunities
some other opportunities so just in the
middle of all those pieces
simultaneously so a lot a lot that I
could I can relate to which you very
well picked up on in my uh in my knots
but it's an ongoing process and as
you've talked about too it's a learning
process so I'm still learning as I go
through and just trying to be open with
people about those yeses and no's even
though they're not easy
yeah it is a journey
um yeah and I would love to hear you
know Dr Ireland is
um
how
what advice or what experiences
um they had in
coping with the emotional part of saying
nose
to people who are in need
even if you know that that no
is completely Justified is the right
thing in terms of priorities and impact
and self-care is
there's a cost with saying no and maybe
there isn't to everyone I don't know
actually I don't know if that if I feel
that
because of my upbringing because of my
faith because I haven't queried it
um until now and so I'd be really
curious
because clearly they have to say no to
people in need to be able to succeed and
survive in those heavy Compassionate
Care
jobs
and and yet how do you deal with that
because as you said so you decide to
give the talk to 50. and it might turn
out that three people of those 50 it's
it is incredibly impactful and
meaningful and it's the right choice and
then the one-on-one mentee you said no
to might feel
you know not that it's irrepo Error um
irreversible but my temporary feel
abandoned or that they're not a priority
and in that decision they were not a
priority and that doesn't mean it isn't
Justified
but that's such a struggle in terms of
what
how to feel about that yeah
yeah
I 100 agree yeah so it's just love
because I have to think through it
um I'd also love to hear just about
um
you know the encouragement that I
suspect is that we're not doing it alone
you know and even you know the you know
many of our faith leaders now and in the
past whatever your belief you know there
are stories across all religions about
people uh in those roles you know
whether it's Jesus or you know whomever
you know being fed being cared for
resting being washed being supported
literally in the case of Christian faith
carrying the cross for
um
You Know It uh to take the burden off
for a while and I've been thinking a lot
about that in the sense of how often
when we get burnt out we
narrow our Circle
and we go internal
and when it's when we need support the
most whether it's just some perspective
or it's just somebody to take a little
bit of the burden off or but we tend to
isolate
um when when we feel burnt out yeah
wow that's really well said you did say
you're not a psychologist but you did
say you have a mother who's a therapist
my mother is a family
yes definitely and you know and in full
disclosure you know we've had a lot of
you know
um
mental health challenges across the
whole family and so and and have had
what I feel is a privilege to talk about
it
you know it's hard to cope when you
literally cannot do something because
your body or your mind tell you you
cannot yeah you know and needing to
accept help and yeah so anyway I you
know I'm not my area of expertise but
putting these two topics Together made
me think a lot about
I'm really curious in the Pastoral Care
realm yeah how these kinds of questions
are thought about and reflected on I'm
sure there will be no answers just like
there's no answers for how we make every
decision around our role as mentors but
to your point earlier
but that were being reflective and
intentional in those decisions yeah
because at least you have an answer for
why I know somebody might challenge or
why but at least you have a life yeah
and the other thing that you know as
your Syrian is really jumping out to me
is just again the importance of
community and my listeners have heard me
say that a lot but even as you were
talking about just how easy it is to
become very narrow in focus and the
importance of community to bring those
outside perspectives sometimes or to
help us to pause and see things from a
different perspective even as you talked
about if someone is in a place of
burnout having someone in community to
help them kind of think about where
that's happening I mean the way that you
were doing that even as we were talking
how important that could be as well my
anticipation would be even in talking
with Dr Ireland the importance of that
Community for him as a leader of leaders
and helping other leaders to remember to
have those bigger perspectives because I
know he's also done boot camps for
pastoral staff and helping them think
through some of those pieces about
I would imagine even though they're
focused on others it can be easy to be
isolated and
driven in that Focus to not have enough
perspective from outside so I think it's
going to be
a great conversation I'll be curious
maybe we'll have I'll try having respond
to some of these uh questions as well
unfortunately he won't be able to ask
you questions that you could then
respond to but perhaps will create some
type of other way for that to happen as
well but I think that's going to be
really it would only be fair right
so you brought up something that is
really interesting that I've been
thinking about a lot too is so you said
do people ask you do you sleep and I
think this is a question of things we
don't talk about either and actually is
probably one of the most important
things in terms of self-care so I'll
answer if you answer
do you sleep how much do you sleep
I do sleep so it depends I think I've
become maybe this is my age catching out
to me more adamant about that as I've
gotten older so whereas before I even
you know in the last two years when I
started this podcast I would tend to let
that stuff kind of go into the night
whereas now I'm trying to be more
particular about just having a shutoff
time
and again this may be the age but I'm
just also in the spirit of what we've
been talking about just paying attention
when we talk about paying attention
things like burnout paying attention to
how much less effective I am as the day
goes on and then just realizing if I
just leave that I'm going to feel behind
but I'm going to do it five times faster
if I come back to it the next day more
refreshed so part of my I think getting
sleep is also again this goes back to
the guilt I don't like leaving things
feeling undone but allowing myself to
say that's fine
and that will actually help me still get
the rest I need and will actually help
me be more efficient and maybe a
refreshed and think through things more
carefully when I come back to it so I'd
say that's kind of my experience it's
not perfect yet there are you know
family responsibilities and activities
and all those things that throw sleep
out the window often not completely but
you know you've always had more but I'd
say from that standpoint
better than I would have expected I
think if I didn't get that I'd actually
probably be in a place of being burnt
out and have to take away one of the
many components that I'm involved in at
the moment
yeah I hear you on that I'm a
my husband says sleeping it's my
superpower
so I do sleep I can sleep anywhere
um and when I'm up I'm up
and when I'm done I'm done that's good
and
um and I am
I've had to Grapple with I'm
I am a less
you know I would have used the word
crabby when I don't sleep or if I don't
tend to my sleep but it is one that I'm
not
as kind as I want to be when I don't
sleep
and somehow being honest with myself
about that made me be able to prioritize
it even more is there something about if
I say to myself not just so I love it
like what you're saying is like letting
it go to the next day because I'll do it
more efficiently and more effectively
I'm I'm on your train on that one and
saying if you choose to stay up you're
probably going to have meetings in which
you're not as kind
as you would strive to be
and and then have to own that
um and so anyway I'm still working on
that too but that narrative to me has
been very interesting
in terms of motivation yeah again just
the level of honesty that you're willing
to have with yourself as well
but then it makes me even more that you
know my children are both grown now but
oh man when they're little and you don't
have any power over the sleeve you're
getting and just trying to make it and
um or if you have other family
responsibilities is so much so much
empathy yeah for that stage of life um
they are
it is challenging yeah yeah and I had
forgotten that until I had been around
family members with young kids again and
it took me back and I didn't know how
I'd forgotten that
yeah well again just really appreciate
you know just your your honesty with so
many different aspects I'm going to
venture a guest to say that this is not
a typical conversation that you have on
a daily basis
um in your work in terms of the things
that we've we've spanned but I really
appreciate we want us to be able to kind
of think through and wrestle with those
two and even as you've brought up the uh
the faith aspect and that's something
that's definitely near and dear to to me
and to what we try to do on this podcast
just to have you know deep honest
conversations about all aspects of our
lives and not get stuck in this kind of
compartmentalizing and pretending that
there are aspects of Our Lives that
exist whether we come from a faith
perspective or not so really appreciate
ruining this and we'll definitely pass
some of those questions along as well
one last question I did want to ask you
know comes from our listeners and
particularly because people are so
excited about this topic of burnout um
so one of our listeners asked how to um
to avoid or at least deal with burnout
and this is specifically within academic
context but it you know expands
elsewhere as well but just just as
people kind of get more and more roles
and responsibilities with Career
Development and achievement and things
like that and uh I won't call it the
problem but the challenge of people who
seem to be doing things well and then
seem to get more and more added onto
their plate and just no just knowing how
to navigate that I don't know if you
have any
specific words of wisdom you want to
share there yeah so I mean I do I think
I'm going to come back to kind of
what I started to share in the Journey
of even writing the piece and then what
I've noticed in my own
practice
is you know and it might sound simple
but
is really and I'll use this already in
querying
burnout
so
um
I was listening to and I uh I'm gonna
embarrassedly I don't remember
um what podcast it was so but don't
worry I will never forget that it's this
podcast but I realized the irony in me
saying that I listened to something and
I didn't remember whose it was
um so sorry to that person but it was
really interesting it was about
um
uh someone who had very very high uh um
high pressure job very you know
leadership position and just felt so
burnt out that they just left
that's it
and then in this um person's
um story they went on um they actually I
think they went and lived on an island
actually
um if if I'm remembering it right and um
for a person if they've ever listened to
this it's going to think I'm completely
slaughtering their story so I apologize
but the basic idea was completely burnt
out decided the only answer was to
completely remove themselves
went and basically did nothing
and then and had the opportunity to do
that you know most of us can't do that
but then missed everything about their
work
and I only raise it because some of the
reflections then that came back they did
then end up being going back to work and
was that it wasn't all the things on
their list
it was perspective they actually
loved most of the work they did
it actually energized them a lot of the
time
they liked their colleagues and working
with them they were passionate about
doing something meaningful
um
but it had all gotten a bit much they
couldn't prioritize they couldn't focus
it was all just too much and they and
the inability to have perspective on it
just seemed like the only thing you
could do was to just leave and I think
we've all been there when we look at
everything we feel we're being asked to
do or we even feel compelled to do and
we go it's impossible
and I think that the querying of it in
the burnout is saying okay it is
probably impossible
so I could go the extreme and do none of
it
that has consequences
or I can think about which pieces I'm
going to do
or not and and then you know obviously
like you said in Community start to
query that and what is draining what is
sustaining how are those balanced
um and so I really do think you know
especially you know the you're if we're
talking about Junior colleagues in
Academia who see this you know place
that they have to get to in order to be
promoted and it feels so high impact and
so high stakes
um and then all of the other things are
being asked to do and compelled to do
and starting to query about what
sustains what burns out what's going to
pay out what's not
um and to not do that alone
I think you know when we do that alone
we everything about our own biases are
all our habits they all play out and
sometimes like we it's interesting we
both talk about coaches someone
reflecting back and you've probably had
this experience back and they reflect it
back and you go oh
right so actually what you've heard me
saying is there's really one major
priority that I want to get done this
month and I should spend time on that
and then suddenly it's clear but I
couldn't see it myself so that may be to
your listeners feel like way too
straightforward but I feel like
examining ourselves is sometimes the
best thing to do and if you feel like it
is impossible without burning out it
probably is but that doesn't mean you
can't get help to find make some choices
yeah
um but it's back to that trapped feeling
um and the drowning feeling that becomes
terrifying and
um and to go back to you know having
somebody walk you through and say if
you're feeling trapped and burnt out
let's come up with seven possible ways
that that could maybe be a little
different and maybe one of those will be
worth trying not just one way
you quit and go to an island you know it
was kind of like yeah that is an option
maybe
for a lot of people not an option
um but I think it's so much about
perspective and I think you know I'll be
curious what Dr Ireland says and I think
that you know
if you
you know have belief in a certain Faith
or even if you don't believe in a
certain religion but you know whatever
your beliefs are about
um what is valued what's important what
those communities can do for you is to
give perspective yeah
and I think at the end of the day that's
often what we're most afraid of but
we're most seeking yes just a different
perspective because we're trapped in our
own head and heart yeah
I 100 agree
that's I mean I think I think that's a
really helpful answer even if it feels
straightforward just and I think you
know as people listen to this they will
have that experience of what you just
mentioned too just hearing it even
though you're not speaking with them in
direct conversations just having that
reflective moment I think will be really
important because it is so my husband
does for me I always say he's my best
partner because
um and I'll I know we're ending up so
I'll just I'll tell a little funny
antidote but so I'll come home sometime
like many I'll complain about everything
that everyone he's asked me to do and
how things are unfair and I'm being
blocked everywhere everything I try to
do is blocked by someone or the system
and you know we've all been there the
world's against us yeah
I can't you know I don't know if I can
do all this work in this job and and
he'll listen and he'll say that sounds
hard
and then he'll say let me remind you
every day you get to go to a job
you feel like means is making a
difference in the world
that people listen to you and sometimes
think you have good ideas
that you have some power it's not as
much as you want but you have privilege
you have and he'll just run the list and
he'll say
and of course in doing it he's not
trying to not validate it he's trying to
just give some perspective
and he and I go and I always say yes I'm
still frustrated but yeah I forgot about
that
um
and so for me and that doesn't work for
everyone and I know that can be
triggering and obviously not everyone
feels like someone's going to be able to
say and here's all your privilege
because not everybody goes to a job
where they feel heard and that the work
they do is Meaningful and valued
but for most faculty
to get to where they are you have been
hired because people believe you have
something to contribute
you have taken that job because you feel
like you have something to give that's
going to change the world that's going
to have impact and that alone is an
amazing opportunity yeah the system is
stinks and lots has to change and it's
not fair and it's not equitable
but for the folks in the academy
um
there are certain beautiful things about
the opportunities to work in a space
like that
it needs a lot of work but it but it
does offer a pretty amazing opportunity
to do that work yeah
highly agree and again just the
importance of community to be able to
remind each other of that the way your
husband has done and to be able to
celebrate those things as they happen I
mean so many ways I've seen communities
look at your job you you get to do a
podcast I mean it's something amazing
thing that this gets to be part of your
work and your mission is just an amazing
thing yeah
yeah how do you feel honored blessed and
privileged in that sense as well and
it's such a such a reminder to me I mean
everything you just shared as guests
have come on and shared that with me as
listeners have continued to share that
um even people who found this podcast
through different means I mean even
meeting with someone this week who said
oh I just saw this pop up into my
YouTube feed and was able to share just
the ways that that the the podcast has
really encouraged them so again as as
you mentioned that that privilege and
that perspective is huge
um in some ways I feel like I've been uh
I've been using this podcast to to
facilitate more of these conversations
because I come away so encouraged from
these types of things as well and for me
I would even say you know this past I
can't even track anymore because it's
been two years almost two years in the
podcast has been so helpful for that
perspective as well and just that
frequent reminder and then again seeing
people who are invested in so many
different areas and walks of life
um I think is really uh
so it's really really touching I don't
even know if I can put words into it per
se as you're actually helping me reflect
and I think you know just projecting It
Forward projecting it onto listeners who
are are tuning in even for those you
know for mayless who have felt feelings
of burnout or getting too close trying
to pull back I think the perspective is
huge and again it goes back to what we
talked about I think at the beginning of
this recording and just the place that
we both seem to be at this moment
um being able to be excited and
reflective and being able to hold on to
that even when the busyness comes so I
appreciate you sharing that story
um from your husband that I mean that's
such that's part I'm going to go back
and listen to again just the way that he
I like how he said that people sometimes
listen to you I mean that's part of it
as well
always yeah yeah but even that sometimes
is still important it's still yeah it's
such a I mean and I think on this topic
of you know I know it's burnout but
mentorship is
as hard as the work can be and as tiring
it can be and we don't want mentors to
be burned out
mentorship is just the most amazing
privileged work
to be able to influence someone's life
one-on-one like that it's amazing
well said and a great parallel to Dr
Ireland coming up yes can't wait to hear
hear his thoughts so
um wonderful well thank you so much for
being here thank you for the work that
you do thank you for taking time to
share so honestly and openly here and
just and practically as well I know that
people are really going to enjoy
listening to this and I hope this will
also generate some conversation in
communities as we've talked about
already today so Dr fun thank you again
I've really enjoyed hosting you thanks
for the opportunity
[Music]